we will shut you down we will cite you
and if we need to we will arrest you and
we will take you to jail period
if June 1st 2023 that means it's pride
month everybody happy Pride to you and
your gay dog and your trans uncle aunt
and everybody you know get out there and
drink some Bud Light and go to Target
and tuck it and all that stuff oh my God
we're so excited here at the Reuben
report I'm Dave
I really was not in the mood to do that
this morning I don't know it was a long
night with the kids the team put me up
to it it's pride month it's like being
smacked in the head with a giant
Sledgehammer may God have mercy on our
souls may we get through these 30 days
and roll into July with our genitals
attached
head on straight
pray if you pray now is the time guys
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals if you have not joined us on
locals yet we do a post game wrap-up
show there every day at
reubenreport.locals.com of course we
have an IOS app and an Android app and
we are doing a Community Q a today after
I hit a couple stories up top so if you
want to still get your questions in last
minute we'll take them on the Fly
reubenreport.locals.com the theme of
today's great program I don't even know
what that voice is exactly it's it's
like what is it I don't know exactly
um the theme of today's program uh I was
watching on the Twitter last night which
Twitter has shifted a little more
towards the the video realm right
they're going a little more in that
YouTube Rumble space which is great it's
just great to see more products more
stuff out there uh the folks at The
Babylon B they did a long form it was
about a little over an hour long
interview with Elon Musk over at Twitter
we're gonna show you a couple clips of
that obviously related to free speech
and everything else that's been going on
lately a little bit of the uh the Trump
DeSantis thing which keeps heating up
and I'm really I think as you've tried
as you've seen uh over the last week or
so since DeSantis has announced I'm
really trying to be fair with this thing
I'm not pretending that that my feelings
are not what they are obviously
obviously I think the Santa is a better
choice
I supported Trump for a long time and
and happened to still like Trump to a
degree I don't like a lot of his
behaviors at the end of this thing
although I would prefer that we have
President DeSantis because I think that
that could fix the country I actually
think that's the thing that could fix
the country if we end up with President
Trump and uh I have a governor Ron
DeSantis right here in Florida that
would be okay too the thing that we
don't want is President Biden or Kamala
Harris or Gavin Newsom God forbid or or
whatever else so trying to deal with
that as as decently as possible and you
just got to remember we're still a year
and a half away from the election which
is just crazy so everyone's going nuts
and it's like calm down everybody and
you know what I'll get to more on that
in just a sec let me talk to you guys
about geniusell and then we will get to
it you know Jen you sell has just
upgraded their most popular package to
feature their top selling deep firming
vitamin C serum plus Ultra retinol
moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative and right now take advantage
of this limited time package upgrade for
70 percent off why waste time and money
to go get work done to your face when
you can get geniusell skin care shipped
right to your door here's a
geniusell.com review from Robert in
blessing Texas I purchased genucel as a
gift for my girlfriend she said she saw
results so fast so we joined their
concierge program immediately it's
honestly the best skin care she's ever
used and is extremely impressed with all
of geniusell's products her skin is
noticeably softer and smoother I can see
and feel a difference she has all she
was already beautiful and geniusell has
made her even more beautiful Jenny cell
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by a compounding pharmacist in
small batches and always safe cruelty
free and natural go to geniusell.com
Dave and save over 70 off Jandy cell's
most popular package featuring both the
genius Ultra retinol and genocell
Firming Serum don't wait go to
geniusell.com
it's geniusell.com and slash Dave and
you'll get a complimentary Spa essential
response with every package plus free
upgrade to priority shipping
geniusell.com Dave okay here we go so
the Babylon B guys sat down with Twitter
CEO Elon Musk at Twitter in the
dystopian nightmare that is San
Francisco and they talked a little bit
about comedy and why it's no longer
funny
the you know the essence of a lot of
Comedy is a revealed truth
um like a hidden truth that people
understand
intuitively or explicitly
um and uh there's a there's that sort of
moment of reveal
you know kernel of true of of often
unacknowledged truth and in that
unacknowledged truth is the humor if
you're
you know premised on a lie you can no
longer be funny because there's no real
truth
um and this is um
in a way a lot you know a lot of people
on the left have no sense of humor
they're not funny yeah he's so right
about that I mean think about think
about the just the evolution of stand-up
comedy over a couple of decades like
just in your own head right now do your
top three favorite stand-up comics like
if I was doing my top three favorite
all-time stand-up comics I've probably
got George Carlin uh number one
for me it would be Georgetown number one
just because of the breadth of the work
I know a lot of people say Richard Pryor
number one I would probably put prior at
two because I think he only had like two
really really great specials Carlin had
probably ten and then I think you could
maybe you could do like uh Bill Maher at
the peak of his stand-up days the point
is all of you right now watching this
you can think of great stand-ups and the
reason you like a stand-up the reason
they make you laugh is there is that
hidden truth and they're sort of getting
you right to that line and then through
the joke they can kind of trip over that
line and that's what the the release is
the releases the laughter but as so many
Comics went woke and became sort of
Lefty lunatics we wrecked comedy to the
point that nobody in there right when's
the last time you met somebody who was
like did you see Saturday Night Live the
other night like how great was that no
like occasionally I play clips of
Saturday Night Live on the show to show
you how horrible it is or how they
wrecked The Daily Show or they or any of
the The Tonight Show The Late Night with
Colbert whatever any of those shows are
they're all hysterical uh sort of
partisan hackery which is why Greg
Gutfeld who's not even a stand-up right
I mean Greg was I don't think he ever
did stand up he's number one in late
night because he's just kind of loose
and silly and it's not hyper produced or
over produced uh and he's doing
something that is closer to the truth
because you know what his actual beliefs
are on these things uh the line if
you're premised on a lie you can no
longer be funny because there's no
reveal of Truth is just particularly
good and I think Elon having gotten to
know him a little bit there's just sort
of like a soft way that he talks about
things in a thoughtful manner that I
think is uh particularly good uh let me
just show you one other clip from the
interview and then I want to just
mention the the physical location of the
interview check out the room that
they're sitting in I'll tell you a
little bit about that this is Elon
talking with the Babylon B guys about
how NPR remember how NPR had a Twitter
fit because he labeled them
state-sponsored media and I'm pretty
sure they're not even on Twitter anymore
because of that even though they are
state-sponsored media and it used to be
on their website take a look
as you've seen we've open source the
algorithm and made at this point I think
well over 100 changes but how will we
stay informed if NPR isn't there anymore
you know at any given point I'm not sure
if NPR is there or not I wasn't aware
that they were there until
they said they were not going to do that
I mean we're trying to apply the rules
consistently
at Twitter so that you know the NPR
thing is like well
um if we're gonna call some media State
Affiliated we'll there's plenty of uh
meet organizations in the US that are or
in the west that are State Affiliated
um so then we should apply the label
equally
um
and then uh they get very upset about
that
um and so that they will stay Affiliated
implies that the state has editorial
authority of an influence over the
content and like
so you're saying you don't have that
right how software are you um
you know it was on their website well
yeah I mean well NPR are literally on
their own exactly on their own website
said you know Government funding is
essential to their operation right and
so we even changed it from uh State
Affiliated to state funded
so that's just literally a statement of
fact right I mean we could actually just
lift the same text from their website
and put it at the label
and but they're still there and they're
unhappy with that yeah they're unhappy
with that the reason I really wanted to
show you this clip I get it none of you
love NPR and you don't care whether NPR
is on Twitter anymore and yes it was a
statement of fact saying you are state
funded media it used to literally be on
nprs.org website that they were state
funded uh but the reason I really wanted
to show you that was because you know we
we deal with all this like woke nonsense
through these corporations and I show
you these clips of the Target CEO or the
Chick-fil-A CEO or the Bud Light
marketing executive all bowing to
wokeness no one's saying what they
really believe all like they're reading
a script you know we showed you even the
the Toronto Blue Jays picture yesterday
you know with his with his really
horrible apology struggle Mouse style
struggle section session where he's just
apologizing for having liked a Instagram
post about a boycott of Target the point
is that so few people are actually
willing to tell the truth or certainly
they're not willing to tell the truth
any sort of nuanced way with a little
bit of humor and everything else and
that's what you know having been to
Twitter a couple times and spent some
time with Elon like the guy is just
trying to do the right thing it's it's
just become so like patently obvious to
me and I think that's important and it's
sort of you know what I always tell you
with to say this it's like he's trying
to do the right thing if that's worthy
of being modeled it's worthy of being
lifted so that other people can
hopefully do that too and he is doing
that I just want to mention one other
thing about the Locale that they're
doing that in so that was at the Twitter
offices and if you go back later and you
rewind and you watch you know they sort
of blurred out the background but it's
so interesting there because they're in
this massive building uh on I I think
it's on Market Street it's a it's a
public building I'm not not boxing
Twitter they've got a big sign that says
Twitter outside
um it used to be like a great area in
San Francisco now obviously with the
homelessness and the drugs and
everything else absolutely horrible
actually I was standing in the office
and Elon was just like pointing around
just showing us where like the worst
pockets of insanity are don't walk down
that street Etc et cetera anyway he came
in there and as you guys know they had
about 7 500 employees immediately fired
half he's still been firing people still
thinks he has people in there that he's
got to get rid of but the point of all
that is they have this huge space that
uh when you talk about dystopia in San
Francisco now you've got a massive tech
company perhaps the most important tech
company in the entire world in terms of
the way we can communicate these days
about the important issues and there's
basically nobody there so what you're
seeing behind them is this giant
commissary that used to be there to feed
three meals a day thousands of employees
and it's just absolutely empty so uh all
that being said Elon if you're watching
today we'd be happy to have you in Miami
uh I want to jump to one other topic
somewhat Loosely affiliated with truth
and lies you may have seen this tweet
two days ago from disgraced former New
York Governor Andrew cuomona of course
Andrew Cuomo you remember Andrew Cuomo
he's the one that ordered all of the
elderly people with kovid back into to
the old age homes thus killing really an
Untold amount of people if you want more
on that story check out my interview
with Janice Dean Fox meteorologist
Janice Dean whose in-laws both died
because of Cuomo policies on that anyway
here's a tweet from Andrew Cuomo from
two days ago Donald Trump tells the
truth finally New York got hit first and
worst but New Yorkers acted responsibly
Florida's policy of denial allowed covid
to spread and that's why they had a very
large second wave so first I just want
to mention it's a little sort of
hilarious to now see Andrew Cuomo and
Donald Trump on the same side but you
know we've also got Donald Trump and
MSNBC on the same side when it comes to
Ron DeSantis
um it's it's also like just a complete
rewriting of history and everything else
Cuomo should be embarrassed for the rest
of his life and never be in public
office ever again after what he did
related to the old age homes and also
even though actually if you look at the
total amount of deaths if we're to trust
these numbers Florida New York had about
the same but it's not about deaths per
se because you have to look at age of
population Florida has the second oldest
population and you also have to look at
what is the role of government was it
the role of government to lock you in
your house who were the officials who
started realizing oh we should get kids
back at school we shouldn't be locking
everyone down and closing businesses and
all of those things so even if one state
had significantly better numbers the
question is are all the Draconian
measures worth it is that what the
purpose of government and having rules
and regulations are that's a debate that
we should all have but if at the end of
the day you think that New York and or
California
Etc did a better job than Florida
I got a bridge to sell you people I
really do anyway Trump's been uh going
after DeSantis relentlessly and
attacking Florida we played the he went
after Kaylee mcenany yesterday which I
think actually has shifted things a
little bit you know it's one thing when
Trump goes after all of like the the
Deep State people or he goes after like
middle management government people CAA
people
etc etc but Kaylee was so outwardly a
defender of him and did it so well at
the height of covid with a hostile media
that I even saw some of Trump's most
loyal backers yesterday finally being
like enough is enough like this guy who
talks about loyalty all the time who has
he not turned against I I ask you I
would ask you that
who has he not turned against how is it
possible that everyone he's ever worked
with is a sellout and a rhino and a
globalist and an idiot whether it's
Christopher Ray or it's John Bolton or
it's Chris Christie or it's Kaylee like
everybody has somehow turned against him
and it's always their fault like it
doesn't quite make sense anyway DeSantis
was campaigning yesterday in Iowa and uh
somebody in the media asked him about
Trump's attacks and Florida I thought
this response was pretty solid
so you talked about uh changing her tone
a little bit with former president Trump
I don't believe you mentioned him here
by name tonight but does this mean
you're going to be a bit more aggressive
with campaigning against him so look I'm
going to respond to uh attacks I mean if
if you say Cuomo did a better job with
covid then Florida did first of all
that's not what he used to say this is
like new like six months ago he would
have never said that right he used to
say how great Florida was hell his whole
family moved to Florida under my
governorship are you kidding me
um
so so some of
some of the thing is look if someone is
saying that I am gonna I'm gonna counter
punch I'm gonna fight back on it I'm
gonna Focus my fire on Biden and I think
he should do the same he gives Biden a
free pass I'm focusing on Biden that's
my focus
you know it's not that hard to speak
clearly when you're telling the truth
right
it's just as simple as that it's not
that hard to be funny when you're doing
something true to link it to what we
were talking about a moment ago but it
is true like all of Trump's family lives
here now uh several of his kids and all
of his grandchildren moved to Florida
during covid because of the policies of
Ron DeSantis Trump is not attacking
Biden at all I would recommend you look
at Trump's truth social feed you could
look at Jason Miller who I think is the
campaign manager look at his Twitter
it's all against DeSantis right and
DeSantis said the right thing I'm not
going to spend all day attacking him but
I will respond to attacks and again the
reason I'm laying this out for you guys
the way I am is I think there is a more
mature way to do all of this and we're
starting to see it it is being born and
I don't think we want it to be stillborn
I think we want it to be born and given
a chance to grow and I think that is
what I will do
as we continue this crazy year and a
half all right we got a Local's
Community Q a for you before we get to
it let me talk to you guys about Old
Guard pet food don't all dog food
companies want the best for your dog
well no not really pet food companies
are pushing trendy ingredients and
expensive recipes like fresh and raw but
are they better No in fact most of no
proven health benefits for your dog also
watches these dog food companies release
bug and vegan recipes it'll show you
where their priorities really are if you
don't want to compromise on high quality
ingredients and want science-backed
recipes real proven science not fouchy
science get Old Guard it's the only pet
food company founded and run by a PhD in
pet nutrition with quality ingredients
like real chicken egg fish oil fish oil
and probiotics old guards recipes are
perfectly balanced with health benefits
as uh and a taste your dog will love
everything including their resealable
bags are made right here in the United
States so right now go to
oldguardpetco.com subscribe to day and
it will be delivered right to your door
using Code Dave for a discount with Old
Guard you don't have to compromise
ingredient quality your dog's health or
your traditional American values buy
from a company that puts your dog first
clients loving the treats and now back
to me okay
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
Casey says it used to be that a person
would get arrested for public indecency
but put pride in front of it and it's
fine why it's so bizarre again
every time we have to cover one of these
stories I go out of my way to say
whatever you want to do as an adult with
another consenting adult in the privacy
of your own home or or at a club or
somewhere where it's adults only do
whatever the hell you want that's my
position on it it's a more libertarian
position I want people to not infringe
on my rights to live as I wish and I
that's a two-way street that's the way I
view it I know some people may have a
slightly different view on it that's
okay too but this bizarre notion that it
has to be done in front of children or
it has to be done in public that you
have to wear assless chaps to celebrate
pride in front of children as some guy
in a dog costume spanks you I just
it's just come on come on we all know
it's not right so that's why it's such a
damn shame because this this lgbtq two
spirit nonsense all these letters
together this ridiculous month you know
what happens every month it starts I saw
it already this morning all of these
companies in America you know you see it
like BMW and all the beer companies and
everybody else they all put their
American logos now or in a logos in a
rainbow on Twitter so if you open up
Twitter you'll see all these American
companies just rainbow their same logo
but with rainbow backgrounds then if you
look at their middle eastern
counterparts you know if you look at
like Mercedes-Benz Saudi Arabia odd no
no rainbow logo there makes you wonder
it's all virtue signaling nonsense and
enough enough is enough guys enough I
will not be celebrating Prime
I mean I think maybe we're going to have
like we were thinking about having
chicken caesar salads for dinner tonight
but I don't know if that's a real
celebration
uh Dave says would you ever do a debate
with Don Jr you representing Ronnie D
and his uh him representing his father I
think it would be a good way to show
conservatives how their policies differ
and you too would be able to shake hands
and agree to disagree so uh actually
um I mentioned this in the post game
show yesterday but I may as well say it
publicly now and is what it is uh you
know I've been thinking for a while Don
and I have been friends for a long time
over a decade before his dad was in
politics and everything else we had a
connection in New York City from way
back when he was doing my show on
SiriusXM probably in like 2011 something
like that
um
got to know each other pretty well we've
broken bread many times together I
consider Kimberly a friend as well blah
blah blah okay
um I obviously as this thing has heated
up and I've been going after Trump I've
been feeling a little bit of like I I
don't want this to ruin friendships I
know that that is very hard these days
it's hard for everybody but I really
don't want it to ruin friendships and I
texted Don a couple days ago and I just
said hey Don you know I know we may end
up on different sides for a while but I
want you to know I value friendship more
than politics and we were friends before
your dad was in and I hope we'll be
friends after within two seconds like as
if he had must have been holding his
phone in his hand he responded with
almost the exact same thing right back
at me almost the exact same thing so we
are totally good we are going to be good
I don't go after the family as you can
see I go out of my way to tell you that
these are good people and all of that
stuff
um and yes I will gladly have a sit down
with Don he doesn't I was gonna say we
do it over a drink he doesn't drink but
we can just do it we can talk politics
and not not talk politics and and all
that stuff and I think everything will
be fine so I'll reach out to him
privately on that one as well Bonnie
says why the hell would Trump attack
Haley mcenany does he kick puppies to
are we absolutely sure he doesn't drink
I really think DeSantis has a good
chance of beating him he can't stop
himself from attacking people he
considers unloyal it's causing him to
lose support he lost me well that's why
I'm saying I think this Kaylee thinks
something shifted there I'm telling you
when when he goes after guys like John
Bolton nobody suddenly is like I love
John Bolton and I can't support you
anymore because of your you turned on
John Bolton or you turned on Christopher
Ray or you turned on Chris Christie or
the long list of people you turned on
Michael Cohen you turned on you know
Comey you nobody cares I'm telling you
there was a a really different tangible
feeling yesterday like people were just
like wait a minute wait a minute it's
too obvious Kaylee's job she was the
front-facing person the press secretary
right how many times have I shown you
videos of ridiculous Corrine John Pierre
that that was Kaylee's job at the height
of covid and you also have to remember
where Karen John Pierre goes against a
lap dog media she was going after a
rabidly insane media impeachments
coveted all of the craziness right and
she could not have been classier could
not have been more cogent cleaner more
prepared the best of what you would want
out of someone working with the
president that you support right so for
him to turn on her and again it's like I
get it he turns on everybody it's part
of the thing and all that
but in this case maybe if if you would
ever listen to the to this guy on his
shoulder instead of always listening to
this guy maybe he could have been just
texted her just texted her and say hey I
was watching Fox this morning I think
you got these numbers screwed up maybe
you could fix that up later she's on Fox
all day long doing different stuff
but unfortunately that he doesn't seem
to have that within him and I I wish he
did and if he'll sit down with me in it
for an interview I will lay it out
exactly like that uh Mike says hey Dave
with all the different companies going
woke followed by Massive boycotts which
company or product was the most
difficult for you to stop supporting I
gotta tell you the the target thing
I don't like beer I'm not a beer guy so
Bud Light is not a problem if if my
class Azul Tequila went woke although
the bottle is pretty gay come to think
of it uh
he would be a problem
um the target thing you know Target
especially as we're new parents here
Target to just go into that store and
everything's kind of cheap you pretty
much can get any anything as I said
yesterday you can get like Elmer's Glue
you can get an air fryer you can get a
basketball you can get a gallon of milk
like it's all basically there there is
something nice about that but really
like I've just had enough of these
stores so you know I but it's one of
those things I also don't want to buy
everything on Amazon because I don't
think that that's good for the economy I
don't think it's good for small
businesses I don't want to give Jeff
Bezos all my money so this is where we
need more and more stores to hopefully
come out and more and more competition
but I know it's getting harder it's
getting harder because of AI because of
Automation and a whole bunch more uh
Kelly says are you finding that the
always Trump people are almost as bad as
the never Trump if Trump truly loves
America he should want what's best for
America well look that's that's partly
why I have tried and I will continue to
try to show Trump that there is an off
ramp here look it is very possible
Trump's going to win this thing and
DeSantis will flare out somehow and it
just won't work and it didn't scale okay
I have done so far what I think is right
and I will continue to do that that's
all that I can do right if I'm going to
do this for a living that's what I could
do I can tell you what I think it is
what it is sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't
um but for Trump
you know I think I think what's
happening it doesn't strike me that he
has a real campaign at the moment I
don't know who's working for him he
doesn't seem to be on the ground that
much he's just sending out uh you know
truth social posts attacking the guy
that he claims to be 30 points ahead of
that makes no sense it just makes no
sense the off ramp here is hey if you
lose a couple of these early States or
you just see the tea leaves changing he
knows DeSantis is not a bad guy the same
way he knows that Kaylee Is Not a Bad
Gal so if he sees the tea leaves
changing he could just step back step
back from the abyss and be like hey it's
actually way more important that the
Republicans get the presidency back
DeSantis actually is a pretty great
Governor yeah I said some crazy
about him but you know it's politics it
is what it is I'm gonna go do some
rallies I'm gonna spend the rest of my
days playing golf and having people
Adore Me and signing things with my big
crazy signature like there's such an
easy out here of being the king maker
the problem is it doesn't go the other
way right because if the DeSantis goes
down and Trump runs well the Santa's
people I think they'll support Trump but
the question is are there enough new
voters and crossover people and
everything else for Trump to win the the
presidency I just don't see how that
could work but it's very clear that the
scientists can bring over crossover
people so it is what it is uh Nick says
no matter how good a candidate DeSantis
might be would winning the presidential
primary really be a positive thing since
it would likely cause Trump to run as an
independent and split the Republican
vote uh aka the Dems win win
um you know there's an issue with ballot
access I think I mentioned this the
other day like the libertarian party and
the green party they are on most ballots
so he could I suppose take over the
libertarian party that doesn't strike me
as the type of thing that he would do I
think he would maybe maybe try to run an
America first party but I don't think
you have enough time to get on enough
ballots and get that access to really
make uh make a move if that's what he
does like if if that really is what he
does to guarantee a Democrat win then
then you you really have to think like
if you're a hardcore Trump guy right now
and you're watching this show and you
think that that's what he would do then
is this really about what's doing what's
best for America or it's doing what's
best for Trump and then you have to
decide whether you want to support that
or not right like that seems pretty
clear to me I I don't think he's going
to do the third party thing again I hope
he just sees the tea leaves he sees the
landscape changing and he likes to be
liked and he should be liked and he
should be thanked and all of that stuff
and then we move on part two of the
movie Tali says how do you see yours and
David's lives have changed since you
became parents and what things have you
found out about being parents your
younger self would not have believed
well
I can give you one barrier media I mean
it's everything it's literally
everything but I give you one very
immediate one which is on Thursday night
uh Luke the boys have been sick they
both had croup which is this kind of
like old man cough and it really it
takes a while to get better and you know
obviously because they're in such Close
Quarters if one of them gets Sigma both
of them get sick David was a little bit
under the weather I was feeling a little
stuffy uh anyway Luke uh out of nowhere
like maybe uh 10 o'clock at night or so
started just vomiting vomiting vomiting
vomiting vomiting and then like had
nothing left in him and he was still
having the the move to vomit and you
know we're obviously we're very
concerned we're freaking out we're
talking to the pediatrician she actually
wasn't in town
so she's like you you know you probably
should go to the hospital he started
getting very pale like we then that's
when we really started getting worried
it was one thing with the vomiting like
maybe it was bad milk or he had had some
yogurt that we thought maybe wasn't like
great or whatever but he started getting
really pale
um we get we start going to the
Children's Hospital and I'll tell you
like it's weird to talk about but like I
literally was like talking to God on the
way there like I was like take me like I
really was like I I like don't don't not
him you take me now like I did whatever
I was supposed to do something like that
it was really nuts by the time we got to
the hospital he was already feeling
better had his color back and all that
stuff and then by the end like I was
blowing on his stomach and getting him
to laugh and all that and it turned out
that it was just it doesn't even matter
what it was he's completely fine
um
all that being said I guess it does
something about perspective and what's
important and all that and I also think
like just relative to what I do here
um it's one of the reasons I don't get
hysterical about things I was never like
crazily hysterical to begin with and my
temperature runs somewhat cool but like
uh when you see the bigger picture yeah
you get it Amy Says prediction time what
is the next company to go woke and get
Bud lighted all right so we've got Bud
Light we've got Target the Toronto Blue
Jays have done it you guys got anything
who's it going to be who's it going to
be that's the next company that's going
to go woke
um it could be I mean the thing is it
could literally be anybody right like
Disney you know what's his name Hank
Azaria from uh The Simpsons who's like
the best voiceover guy ever won't do
wapu anymore it's all so stupid it
Rampages through everything it creates
nothing except bad products basically
and hostility what's the next company I
who there's just no way you could guess
because it literally could be anybody uh
Elizabeth says what's your favorite
thing you and David have done with the
boys so far is there a particular outing
that was more fun than the others
they're such cuties
um you know we did the beach thing with
them which was tough it really was tough
it was a hot day we went around like 11
A.M which was you know like peak of the
day and you know you build a tent and
it's sweaty and poop and sand getting
everywhere and milk is warm and like it
was it was a lot and it's hot in the car
and all that stuff the boys are like
unbelievably well behaved and they
barely cry and they're always smiling
and like we're really blessed in that
sense but that was a tough day
um we have a we have a great a really
great Botanical Garden not too far from
us and we take them there and we kind of
wander through and
you know there's all sorts of birds and
there's Turtles and fish and all kinds
of that that stuff we just it'll take
some uh some pellets and throw it in the
water and like yeah that's just like a
nice calm place you know just botanical
gardens in general or Pleasant and
lovely so there you go uh Leslie says
what do you think about what's Sunny
Hosten said on The View about white
women voting the way their husbands do
myself I am libertarian my husband is
full-on Republican and we are quote
unquote white so if you didn't see it we
spared you guys did we play one clip
from The View this week nothing
nothing from The View this week you're
welcome people uh Sunny Hosten who is
just a deeply unlikable racist lunatic
she basically said that Republican men
have in essence scared their wives to
the point that their wives then vote
Republican I actually think this is
completely the reverse and I've
mentioned this before I've called this
the Theory and the
theory is that the average guy goes to
work does whatever he does he comes home
and he just wants peace and it would be
nice to get a and his wife women
tend to be more Democrat for a series of
reasons a lot of it has to do with the
pro-life thing or whatever whatever the
reasons are especially middle-class
women right so the guy generally doesn't
want to get into politics because he
would like a and you can't blame
him for it
this is they're not doing this on MSNBC
I'll tell you that much anyway uh I
think actually it's the reverse of what
Sunny Hosten said I don't think the men
are pushing the women to be Republicans
I think a lot of the women have so
grabbed these guys by the balls that the
men are voting Democrat or at least
saying they're voting Democrat just to
keep peace in the home and get the
occasional I really think that
you can that's what it's going to say
years from now on Dave rubin's Wikipedia
what did he do he came up with the great
Theory cool mom says it feels
like we won't have any choices or
products left to purchase soon are there
wealthy Republicans talking about going
in on any Ventures who can we uh buy
from uh besides Amazon yeah you know
I mean I sort of addressed this already
we just need more and more competition
we need that parallel economy on all
fronts look what I think you know
Twitter has shifted in in our Direction
obviously what we're doing with Rumble
and locals that's on the tech side uh we
need there are now dating apps literally
for uh you know the Big Ten conservative
thing uh we need everything like stop
funding your own demise so next time you
need you're like you know what I need
today I actually have to pick up an air
fryer and some glue and a basketball and
a gallon of milk Target's right there
but actually I could drive a little bit
further and go to this other store
you know what you might want to do that
and I know it's a pain in the ass and we
and I'm not sitting here telling you I
never ordered from Amazon or that I'll
never walk into a Target again we all
have our own pressures we all have
nonsense going on like all that stuff
but I think uh I think if you just do
whatever it is you can do in your life
like even if it doesn't affect the grand
scheme of things like I think it gives
you a little something and that probably
is worth it uh Angel says if Trump wins
the nomination and the presidency who's
going to want to work for him it seems
like he throws everyone under the bus I
think this is a major problem that's
what I'm saying who's working for him
now who are his surrogates now you know
there's a couple people online that I
see just like relentlessly screaming and
saying crazy things about DeSantis all
day long but I don't know who's really
working for Trump who's in that inner
circle you know when I've been around
the DeSantis team he's got a freaking
tight team of people and you can and
they they all seemingly are Pros his
team doesn't have leaks there's a
there's a machine being built behind him
that you can see Will Be an Effective
machine if it was to move on to the
White House is there any reason to
believe that Trump who had all the leaks
and and I get it the machine was working
against him and they've thrown
everything at him and all of that fine
but is there any reason to think that
suddenly he'll be in the white house
again like imagine if it actually
happened and then suddenly he won't have
the leaks and he'll have great people
around him like if you if you were a
great
uh let's say someone who wanted to be
press secretary right so what Kaylee was
what Corrine Jean-Pierre is now would
you want that risk right so Trump had
Sean Spicer who I had on last week at
Sarah Huckabee Sanders he had Kaylee I
think there might have been one other
one if I'm not mistaken uh but like who
would want that job knowing knowing for
sure that he will turn on you if you
ever say anything that's a huge problem
and and keep you have to staff with so
many people and also remember this the
whole uh the whole energy the whole
inertia behind what he's doing right now
is I'm going to drain the swamp if
you're going to drain the swamp you need
a freaking Army of All-Stars behind you
I just don't see how those people
materialize correct me if I'm wrong uh
cam says what are your thoughts on doing
away with the Federal Reserve from what
I've read the FED isn't really doing the
job it was created to might we be better
off with a monetary board that meets
frequently and is made up of real
economists yeah you know the the
it yes
in essence yes I would recommend that
you watch a couple videos by uh Ron Paul
who's been talking about this for
probably about 40 years but the Federal
Reserve has probably long uh passed its
uh expiration date you know nothing that
we're doing monetarily makes sense
anymore all of this debt ceiling fight
and you know yesterday we announced
another 300 million to Ukraine like all
of the money stuff seems like it's made
up we know that half of the country or
at least one of the political parties
now believes you can endlessly print
money and that money shouldn't be backed
by anything say the gold standard they
don't believe that that then causes
inflation so that when they print money
they then also will at the same time
write something called the inflation
reduction act as they're causing
inflation so
I don't know we could use some seventh
grade math I suppose maybe that would be
a good first step uh Kristen says if
DeSantis manages to win the primary and
become the GOP nominee who do you think
he should choose as his VP pick and why
I think it should be you
oh god
um probably not me uh I'm very happy
here in Florida if for no other reason
that I don't want to leave Florida right
like I don't want to go to DC it I don't
like it I used to like DC I don't like
it maybe I would like it if he was
president and actually when Trump was
President there was a Cool vibe in DC
but I just love Florida my life is good
I don't think I want to do that uh if I
was ever called on to serve in some way
it's not going to be for vice president
but if I ever got a call would you serve
your country in XYZ capacity of course
there would be some conversations about
it but I love I genuinely I love what
I'm doing my life is good right now I'm
working on a whole bunch of other things
that we hopefully will be laying out for
you guys over the next couple months and
like it's all good here
um who would be a good VP choice for him
well I'll give you a couple interesting
ones for sure how about a Tulsi gabbard
how about a disaffected
former Democrat current member of the
military serving right now widely liked
by that let's say center-right and some
center-left people who are the people
who could shift their vote
um you know she's she's extremely well
spoken and just really really nice and
pleasant she actually came by last week
she was in town for a minute just came
by to see boys she's just great human
being and wouldn't that be nice and as I
always say think how different the
Democrat Party would feel right now if
Biden would have chose her instead of
koala Harris there would have been an
iota of Sanity over there which there is
not right now so I think she would be a
really interesting choice it would also
show you know because DeSantis clearly
is to the right at this point of trump
it might also show a little more
crossover appeal that again would help
with those Center people who are trying
to make some sense of what's going on
here I think that's one
um look there's there's identity
politics versions of this where it's
like you could take a guy like Tim Scott
who happens to be you know excellent
Senator I think and then it does like
check some idiotic you know you don't
want to do it because of that but it
does check a box but I guess choosing
Tulsa he also checks a certain boxing
that she's a woman
um I could see him going a completely
other route like you could you could
take a guy a guy like Glenn Younkin and
be like all right now we have two
freaking highly competent
absolute gubernatorial All-Stars and we
are now assembling the Dream Team here
right and now let's figure out who does
that put us with as attorney general and
Surgeon General and you know all all of
the other Primo positions right
um
I think that one could sort of be
interesting I'll try to throw you one
more that might be a little more out
there
well it's not going to be true
I'm telling you now he's not going to be
Trump and Trump is not going to choose
DeSantis like we just have to accept
that that is what it is but anyway it
should be it should be interesting and
we shall see we got one more question
for you did we lose that one last
question oh there we go uh Ray says what
is your favorite summertime spot uh you
know we have a I can't tell you exactly
because if I tell you then some weirdo
is going to show up there and ruin it
for me but there is a spot not too far
from my house that has a great little
outdoor bar
it with a beautiful view and just I get
my little uh I'm usually doing uh the
Paloma I like a Paloma and I just sit
and chat and you know David and I don't
get out too often now we like to cook
anyway so we never went out a ton
usually if we're doing something it's
with the team uh but now with the boys
it's particularly hard to get out but
like we'll just every now and again if
Grandma's in town we can get out and
just go relax and uh but I would say by
and large like my favorite summertime
spot overall like you can be a good day
on the beach I guess I'm in that case
Grandma's watching the kids and we're
just kind of laying there watching the
ocean I am very happy and good to go I
feel very good about this q a today we
did a little bit of everything uh the
tone was just right and on this pride
month let's just you know continue to be
very prideful about immutable
characteristics because that's the most
important thing about us okay we've got
a cold close for you and then we'll see
everybody at reubenreport.com
reubenreport.locals.com and just what
what voice is that that's a different
boy
tough all right see ya
gonna need to go ahead and move you
downstairs into storage BB
that could be some new people coming in
and we need all the space we can get but
there's no space so if you can just go
ahead and pack up your stuff and move it
down there but that would be terrific
okay
excuse me I believe you have my stapler
[Music]
thank you